now there's growing evidence that
russian soldiers are using rape as a
weapon of war in ukraine in areas
retaken from russian troops civilians
are giving horrifying accounts of sexual
violence ukraine's human rights
ombudsman has received hundreds of
reports that the true numbers are
impossible to calculate dw's rebecca
ritters went to bucha on the outskirts
of kiev a place already notorious for
russian soldiers killing civilians she
heard the story of one young woman whose
parents still don't know exactly what
happened to her a warning our viewers
may find this report distressing
this is karina yeshova she was about to
turn 23 when russian soldiers marched
into her town
butcher on the outskirts of kiev
karina had plans she was managing the
local sushi bar but was saving money to
study at university
this is the last place where shaw karina
was seen alive
the stairs outside her flat
it was march 10th
after this everything becomes unclear
this is where one man thinks he saw
russian soldiers kill her but he can't
be sure if the woman was karina or
someone else yes
he put her here
like this
her head was bent back then he took her
in his arms and carried her over there
then another soldier
this is where police told karina's
parents they found the body they said it
looked like she'd been raped
the police said that she was badly
tortured
my girl wanted to live so much
she even applied tourniquets to herself
to stop the bleeding
then with a shot at the head they killed
her
forensic scientists examining the
hundreds of bodies the russians left
behind say many of the women have been
raped
across the country support those who
survive
after 12 cases we're working on
11 are cases of gang rape
[Music]
in all of these cases women reported
that the occupiers were drunk or had
taken drugs
in all 12 cases it was unprotected
intercourse which means a huge risk of
unwanted pregnancy and disease
ukraine's commissioner for human rights
tells me the sheer number of calls makes
them think russians are using rape as a
weapon
when a russian soldier rapes a ukrainian
woman a girl a boy an elderly woman they
keep saying things like this will happen
to every nazi [ __ ] or we will rape
until you can't give birth to ukrainians
these are signs of genocide of the
ukrainian people
[Music]
for carina's parents the only certainty
they have is their loss and their fury
we hate the russians
i'm ashamed to speak russian i will
learn ukrainian
they buried karina here in biliterko
near the morgue
two weeks after her 23rd birthday
joining me now is dw's rebecca ritters
who filed that report from ukraine
rebecca welcome you've just spent the
last month
in ukraine can you tell us more about
the evidence that you heard
that suggests russian soldiers are using
rape as a weapon of war
well as the human rights ombuds woman
said in the report they
see the numbers of the of the
testimonies coming in or the calls that
they're receiving
and they're extrapolating and they're
saying that you know obviously this is
systematic uh by those numbers and not
just kind of one-off cases um you know
as you mentioned in the lead into that
report's really difficult to to get
numbers and they're of course expecting
them to grow but one official number
we've heard from the ombudsman's office
is 400 uh 400 calls in the first two
weeks of april but they are expecting
that number to grow they're they're
primarily from the regions around kiev
the capital as as that was liberated in
april and you know when you look at
places like mariupol um they're
expecting to see a lot more cases in
other parts of the country particularly
in those regions uh you know in the time
to come so i think the the number really
speaks to
it being used systematically so
potentially the tip of the iceberg is
there anything being done to protect
women from this
uh it's really difficult to protect
women against these crimes clearly but
some organizations have i've spoken to
are providing emergency contraception
for people in conflict areas of people
that are in newly liberated areas i know
that one norwegian organization that i
spoke to for instance was going into
those areas around kiev and delivering
emergency contraception um
there's a little bit of a taboo around
that topic in in ukraine so it does make
it difficult but that was happening so
that women can try and prevent
pregnancies from the rape but from the
act itself um yet very difficult to
prevent um can you tell us what's being
done in ukraine to document what is
actually happening to these victims of
rape
uh there are call centers for this
particular crime that's set up by the
human rights ombudsman and organizations
that are helping like the one i spoke to
lustrata and others uh like it are then
funneling information to uh to the human
rights office and to the prosecutor the
prosecutor has around 8 000
investigators and they're going into
these areas and talking to people and
trying to document all the war crimes
they've documented more than 8 000 cases
of war crimes of which you know several
hundred of rape um
in terms of turning these particular
crimes into testimony legal testimony
can be quite difficult because a lot of
the people calling are calling for
psychological help and many of them you
know due to taboo around this and due to
the just the traumatic situation of
these of these crimes um don't
necessarily even want to leave their
names or where they were so it can be
difficult the ombuds woman was telling
me to then transfer them
to testimony but they are documenting as
much as they can and they they swear
that they're going to be bringing this
to justice now rape in war zones often
does go undocumented how likely is it
that russian soldiers who are guilty of
rape
will be brought to justice well yeah
very difficult honor as you say and this
has been going on in russia during the
donbass conflict so for eight years
they've been documenting these cases
it's very difficult to bring them to
justice as well uh the prosecutor you
know is is very adamant that they are
going to ensure that these these cases
be brought to justice um they're setting
up what uh like a war crimes tribunal
similar to the ones post rwanda and post
bosnia and they hope that they will be
able to you know bring from the highest
levels down i mean people wanting to
even bring you know make sure that
president putin pays for these crimes
but as the ic um russia is not signed up
to the icc as we know so it will be
difficult but you know even president
zolensky himself saying he's determined
to make sure that that people get tried
for these crimes dw's rebecca ritters
thank you
catalina busole is a ukrainian lawyer
specializing in international
humanitarian and criminal law and she
joins us now from london thanks for
being with us katrina how likely is it
that the perpetrators of prey of rape in
the ukraine war will ever be brought to
justice
um good afternoon and um i must say that
the attention of the international
community and actually of domestic
investigators and prosecutors in ukraine
towards sexual violence has been
unprecedented since february 2022
but it's important to stress that of
course russia's actions russia's
aggression towards ukraine started much
early in 2014 and during that period
although there were quite numerous
reports about rapes and other forms of
sexual violence such as sexualized
torture or threats of rapes to a
survivor or to his or her family member
there were not enough domestic
prosecutions there was only one
communication to the international
criminal court prepared and there were
no
so far as we know prosecutions at the
domestic levels in other countries in
foreign state under the principle of
universal jurisdiction now with these
new accounts horrific accounts of rape
and other forms of sexual violence post
february 2022 we see that this
particular alleged war crime potentially
a crime against humanity and the
potential
crime of genocide as mentioned by ombuds
woman denisova receives far more
attention so at this point it's crucial
to harmonize all the documentation
efforts to ensure that they're
sensitized and that they don't
re-traumatize the survivors because
there's already a problem that several
survivors are being
interviewed by human rights lawyers
investigators and prosecutors for
several times which of course caused the
additional trauma for them and then of
course to see how these cases proceed
not only to the ukrainian courts and the
prosecutor general seems to pay
particular attention to sexual violence
now but also to foreign jurisdictions
where many survivors end up as refugees
and also to the international criminal
courts
gathering testimony and evidence in such
sensitive cases is difficult what do you
see as the main challenges in bringing
these cases to prosecution
as i mentioned there are two challenges
to harmonize the documentation efforts
at first because so many actors are
involved now in the conflict that has
been ongoing for eight years but the
activation of efforts domestic and
especially international has happened
only post february 2022 so there should
be more of coordination between the
numerous human rights ngos documentation
initiatives uh their harmonization of
their efforts with those of ukrainian
investigators and prosecutors and of
course also there should be more
alignment in terms of what focus will uh
the foreign teams that consult ukrainian
prosecutor office of the prosecutor
general and the investigative team of
the icc uh what they will have uh and
this is important to ensure in
particular with such
sensitive group of survivors survivors
of sexual violence and pre-february this
year ukraine uh to my knowledge and to
what i have seen in my legal practice
there have not been children assaulted
before february this year so there
should be a particular attention as to
how to document this evidence not only
harmoniously but also
in terms of sensitivity and respect for
survivors
now you've said in the past that there's
been a tendency to over focus uh on rape
as a weapon of war
what do you mean by that
in the context of ukraine unfortunately
to the country uh the u.n uh
made a conclusion in 2017 that rape and
sexual violence were not used as a
weapon of war however the human rights
organizations uh um for instance the
east ukrainian center for civic
initiatives that has worked consistently
with survivors of sexual violence in the
russia ukraine and conflict since 2014
have claimed that they did see the
targeted use of sexual violence through
as i mentioned not only rape but
sexualized torture the
threats of torture and mutilation to a
detained person or his or her relatives
so this tendency has been there
perpetrated by russians in ukraine since
the early years of the conflict what we
are noticing now though uh is the new a
scale of this violence be uh it's
spreading to children and to the elderly
people and also this very disturbing uh
rhetorics that could ring a bell about a
possible genocidal intent and in the
report you you provided the quotations
from ombuds woman denisova who said that
rape survivors uh post february this
year in ukraine claimed that the
russians accompanied rape with the words
that um
it was perpetrated for women not to want
to have sex with ukrainian men and not
to give birth to these so-called nazi
children or that the women should learn
the lesson and that that would be
perpetrated towards every alleged nazi
[ __ ] so this sends a very strong
a suppressive threatening message to a
woman or a man who is being assaulted to
their family members because there are
also allegations of rapes in front of
family members and the larger message to
the society about this subjugation
through through the assault on a very
intimate sphere of every human being
their sexual sphere
catalina thank you very much for talking
with us that was catalina bouzou a
ukrainian lawyer in london specializing
in international law
thank you